guten morgen
guten tag
guten tag guten abend
guten abend gute nacht
gute nacht
schlaf gut schlaf gut
auf wiedersehen
bis bald bis bald ein schönes wochenende
ein schönes wochenende
schöne feiertage
wie geht es dir wie geht es dir
wie geht es ihnen
wie geht es ihnen mir geht es sehr gut
mir geht es sehr gut
mir geht es nicht so gut
mir geht es nicht so gut wie heißen sie
wie heißen sie
ich heiße markus hörmann
ist ihr name
wie ist ihr name
mein name ist linda strauß
mein name ist linker strauß
woher kommen sie
woher kommen sie ich komme aus
österreich
ich komme aus österreich
kommen
auch aus österreich
kommen sie auch aus österreich
ich komme nicht aus österreich
nein ich komme nicht aus österreich
ich komme aus deutschland
wo wohnen sie
wo
wohnen sie
ich wohne in wien
ich wohne in
und sie und sie
ich wohne in münchen
wie alt sind sie
ich bin 34 jahre alt
und sie wie alt sind sie
ich bin 42 jahre alt
was ist ihr beruf
was
ist ihr beruf
mein beruf ist anwältin
mein beruf ist anwältin als was aber
si
als
warten sie
ich bin buchhalter
buchhalter
sind sie verheiratet
sind sie
verheiratet
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet ich bin
ledig
und sie sind sie verheiratet
sie sind sie verheiratet
ja ich bin verheiratet
haben sie kinder
ja ich habe einen sohn
was
deine hobbys was sind deine hobbys
ich mache yoga
ich mache yoga ich spiele gitarre
ich spiele gitarre
ich höre gerne musik
ich schwimme gerne ich schwimme gern
meine hobbys sind schwimmen musik hören
und gitarre spielen
was machst du in der freizeit
[Musik]
ich schlafe
ich schlafe gern ich shoppe gern
ich shoppe gern ich treffe gern freunde
ich treffe gern freunde in meiner
freizeit lese ich gern bücher
in meiner freizeit lese ich gern bücher
ich mache oft sport
herren
tanzt
ja ich tanze gern
nein ich tanze nicht gern nein ich tanze
nicht gern
kannst du gut
kochen
ja ich kann gut kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen
siehst du oft fern
ja ich sehe oft fern
nein ich sehr selten fern
nein ich sehe selten fern
wie oft rufst du deine eltern an
wie oft
rufst du deine eltern an
ich rufe sie selten an
ich rufe sie jede woche an
ich rufe sie jeden tag an
wohin geht
gehst du
wohin gehst du
ich gehe in die schuhe
ich gehe in die schule
ich gehe in die stadt
ich gehe ins restaurant
ich gehe in den park ich gehe in den
park
ich gehe in den supermarkt
ich gehe nach hause
kostet das t shirt
viel kostet das t shirt
es kostet 19 euro
[Musik]
kostet der pullover
wie viel kostet der pullover
er kostet 49 euro
wie viele
kostet die jacke
wie viel
die jacke sie kostet 289 euro
sie kostet 289 euro
wie viel
kosten die schuhe
wie viel kosten die schuhe
sie kosten 99 euro
nicht vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren und zu teilen möchtest du
noch weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video